yes so i've been privileged to have
spent so much time with lily growing up
which is quite unusual spend so much
time with your great grandmother and so
during the lockdown being separated for
her for the first two months of the
first lockdown it was actually quite
hard and i realized how precious she was
and how special she was and that these
are really the last moments to hear from
holocaust survivors like lily so with it
being our best option we took to social
media because lily was no longer able to
go to schools and colleges and
universities to share her story
and so i took to twitter and i started
sharing her story and then as you
mentioned earlier we also set up a tick
tock which now amazingly has over 1
million followers and it's just amazing
to have a platform where people want to
hear and ask questions to a holocaust
survivor every single day and everything
just snowballed so fast and we've now
written early story down in a book which
will stay for many generations to come
lily i wonder if you can take us back to
to that point in 1945 that led all the
way to this book when you received a
bank note with a message of support on
it from a from american gi
yeah it was a very special moment when i
get it
because on this banknote was a very
important message and this
soldier want to tell me i should carry
on with my life
and what i did and i
try to carry on and give something for
the humanity still
yeah dave i mean it is important for
those who don't have the personal
connection with the holocaust which lily
survived
for these stories to continue to be told
but we were just hearing in the
introduction there that that lily did
manage to to get to to find at least of
the family of this american gi tell us a
bit more
yes so as i said i we took to social
media to share lily's story during the
lockdown and i wanted her to show me
some things that i could post on twitter
and one of the many relics she showed me
was this german banknote and this
banknote when she showed it to me i saw
it was inscribed with 10 words ten words
of hope it said the start to a new life
good luck and happiness and when i saw
this i was instantly shocked i'd never
seen this before from lily but i also
realized how special it was
and after all lily had kept it for 76
years because it was really so special
because it shows people how kind the
liberators were to the survivors and how
they helped the survivors get back to
humanity and so i remember joking with
lily that i would post this on twitter
and find the soldier within 24 hours and
i posted it and it went viral and it
turned into an international hunt for
the mystery soldier the unknown
liberator
and we managed to find him within eight
hours and it was just an absolutely
incredible moment and i think it shows
people that there is a good side of
twitter and rightly so and social media
where rightly so we're always taught the
dangers of social media and hate can
spread so easily but we also have to
know that there is a positive side and
and you can use it for good to share
education and to share survivor
testimony and stories i mean
lily you're you're smiling broadly there
but you survived one of the the darkest
moments in in human history and and that
you are still able to smile when we're
discussing it tangentially is so
positive but why was it important to you
for this story to be told
because that is really not a story that
is alive what i went through this life
people really the aim was not that after
75 years or even more
i should be here
and tell
my story
they wanted really to kill all of us
that was the aim
and what i promised myself
if
by chance i said by miracle i survived
i will tell the world
what really happened there
but for how bad humanity can be
when they are really bad
and i promise myself for my whole life
that will be my aim tell my story for
the world
that what happened what really happened
there because i am not a second year
generation i was there i am a survivor i
saw why
the world's
root would write it in human history
what really
should not happen and normally could not
happen
and i am here and i promise
and i keep my promise i tell the world
and i am doing
for one mind i have one aim
one aim the world should not should know
that we
should be really tolerant with each
other that nobody is super real so
somebody else and we will know that this
simple thing
and be
nice to each other and instead killing
the world will be a much nicer place to
be me
what a lovely sentiment um from your
great grandmother there dove and i have
to say from personal experience taking
these kind of first-hand accounts and
putting them down and saving these
stories for for generations to come is
incredibly important my great uncle um
left germany fled germany in the 30s
managed to get all his way to scotland i
only discovered a recording of an
interview that he had given to a museum
talking but he died a few good few years
ago i only discovered a recording of his
memories of that time a few weeks ago
and just listening to those stories with
a personal connection and even without a
personal connection keeps the story of
what happened to you lily and and and
many many others alive
yes i think it's as you say it's
incredibly important to share these
stories and to record them forever
because as lily said when when the
witnesses the living witnesses are no
longer here it will become a history and
what's so important to note is that
lilly's story is not the typical story
of the holocaust the typical story is
not told the typical story involves
obliteration of entire families villages
or communities
and so it's so important that now when
lily is still alive and he's 97 and most
of the holocaust survivors are not much
younger and there really aren't many
left especially in the uk so it's so
important that we write these stories
down so that the next generation can
hear them not just hear second-hand
stories from people like me fourth
generation third generation or second
generation but can read them directly
from survivor's words and in lily's
promise that he writes so movingly in
her own words about what happens her and
her family and i think it's so important
that people learn from it because as
lily always says as my great-grandma
always says the holocaust did not start
in the holocaust did not start to
auschwitz it didn't stop by the final
solution and it didn't start by gas
chambers it started with words it
started with basic hatred and we all
have to be vigilant and there are so
many lessons we can learn and i hope
from our berkeley's promise people can
learn a lot and find it really mean a
really meaningful
life lesson lily i i want to kind of
possibly give the last word to you in
fact you go on you were about to say
something there you'd go on
yes
that
well you should listen to us me daily
because in a short time
nobody will be here for really who went
through this terrible
it's it will be already history and
history
it
makes a big difference
from really what you went through
because when i speak about it it is not
history i went there i was there
and luckily most people
thank god i really happy will not speak
anymore will not know
that they better they cannot see them i
was there
i heard it but i don't heard it i went
through it i went through the world's
experience in this
century but people would not believe
that something
like a death
can happen
and it happened
and i wanted the aim was really our
generation should be nobody here they
wanted
kill all of us they didn't need that
victim to disco cruelty what they did
but a few of us
are still here but the trouble is very
few can talk about it and i am telling
you the word now as long as i can
that be tolerant to each other
that is a remarkable message for us to
all take away with us and a good point
for us to conclude lily dove been my
absolute pleasure talking to talking to
both of you really appreciate your time
thank you so much